you said no more television but then I
thought what should ask would you ever
do a TV show with Chris like a reality
docu we've been getting a lot of offers
to do that so right now I'm just
deciding if I want to do that or not but
maybe it'd be hard on a relationship to
do it is I've done it for a long time if
he knew for him because he's never done
something like that he's more of an
actor so it'd be something new for him
definitely
Paris Hilton told ET she's keeping her
options open for a reality TV return
with her fiance Chris zoca at the fourth
annual fashion Los Angeles Awards
presented by the daily front row on
Sunday but inside the bash Paris had a
simple life reunion with Nicole Richie
check out the two smiling from
ear-to-ear as if no time has passed both
Paris and Nicole had the honor of
presenting during the awards show I'm
wearing all Philip Lyon I'm presenting
an award tonight room for fashion rebel
of the year
so first decked out in one of my
favorites you do show up to these red
carpets and like the best designers in
the entire world is it hard to sort of
narrow down who you want to work on
wedding with when you are friendly with
so many great designers
yes that's why I'm going to definitely
have some outfit changes for the wedding
to fit in all my friends that are
designers
[Music]